shopping malls and retail plazas are
slowly reopening in Wuhan City where the
corona virus first emerged but
everywhere
there are reminders that these are still
different times a sign advises shoppers
to wear masks and keep a safe distance
from others I'm very excited because
Wuhan has been shut down for a long time
the Wuhan International Plaza is very
representative of the city so it's
reopening really makes me feel the city
is coming back to life before people are
allowed in there temperature is checked
and they have to show a mobile phone
code that certifies they're in good
health
China has reported a drop in new
coronavirus cases for the fourth day in
a row after restrictions on foreign
travelers reduced the number of imported
cases but elsewhere in the Asian region
countries are tightening their rules
Australia's two most populous states New
South Wales and Victoria are limiting
public gatherings to just two people
from a previous limit of 10 in Vietnam
the Prime Minister has asked local
officials in major cities to prepare for
possible lock downs the number of
confirmed cases there has reached nearly
200 and non-essential services have
already been ordered to shut till at
least mid-april even in countries which
have avoided strict measures the
economic fallout has been severe South
Korea says they'll make an emergency
cash payment to all families except the
richest 30 percent a move that will cost
the government more than 800 million
dollars but these scenes of life slowly
returning back to normal in Wuhan offer
hope to many I'm very excited and happy
for the first day of reopening today I
think being able to be healthy and leave
the house and meet with other colleagues
who are also healthy is a very happy
thing it might seem very ordinary but
after enduring the epidemic being safe
is a blessing Florence lui al Jazeera